hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book nine of
his nikka McCann ethics Aristotle is
going to make a case for us why it is
that we really do need friends whether
we're in good times prosperity or in bad
times hardship yeah it's going to be
furred for different reasons so let's
take a look at their the reasons what it
is that a friend actually does for us or
why it is that we need friends in our
lives we look at bad times hardship
right Aristotle says that those who are
unfortunate those who say have
encountered some sort of disease or a
calamity or who have something wrong
going out of their family those who have
lost their job those who are
experiencing difficult grief you know
all these sorts of things are what we
could call hardships in a person like
this needs assistance that's part of
what a friend is therefore to supply
what it is that we're relaxing and
aerosol of course is not the first
person we came up with us this runs
throughout the literature of antiquity
the notion that it's really in bad times
you can tell who really are friends with
you you know you suffer a major
depression who actually calls on you and
checks on you and tries to you know help
you out and support you you incur some
sort of financial loss who's going to be
there with the the loan or perhaps even
the gift to help you get back on your
feet that's when you can tell the people
who are just hanging around because they
like to be friendly from the people who
are really friends or something says
that we in cases like that we
particularly need the useful friends
right the people who are going to
provide us with some benefits this
doesn't mean that we only need people
who are friends on the basis of utility
because if you remember correctly people
who are good people will be useful to us
they will provide benefits that's part
of what it means for them to be good
people so French friends in terms of
virtue will also be in this case useful
friends and this is where they they will
show their usefulness right another
thing that goes along with this and this
is really quite interesting Aristotle
says that sadness or pain Liu Bei in
Greek is eased in some way or lessened
or taken away by sharing it with friends
so being able to have them there being
able to say your piece to unburden
yourself to complain to to vent as we
often say plays an important role within
friendships in terms of harsha now what
I can notice that it probably Arizona
doesn't say when people are doing what
they ought to be engaging in this but
perhaps there's some scope for it he
does say that this is something that we
don't have in a real hard and fast rules
for and we don't even fully understand
this by itself he says as well and there
was an interesting dynamic that goes a
lot of us sharing this fortune I want to
to read this to you because it's it's
quite important it says the pleasure
that the company of friends give
is of a mixed nature it's true that the
very sight of that was pleasant
especially in time of misfortune and is
a considerable help in a swaging sorry
so you know our friends showing up when
we're when we're sick our friends
actually being there rather than saying
yeah take care of yourself you know when
we're having some sort of psychological
crisis when adversity has hit us then
that you know we we enjoy seeing them
and says if a friend of tactful can
confront and comfort us with lily and
word if he knows our characters and what
things give us pleasure and pain but on
the other hand to see another ping bar
by our own misfortunes can be painful so
on the one hand we would like our
friends to be there right on the other
hand the closer they are to us the
better they know us the more we know
that our misfortune is going to pain
them so what happens in a lot of cases
people conceal what's going on with them
not necessarily because it's shameful I
mean that's sometimes the issue you know
there's some some you know palapa
lenient thorn in the flesh that you
don't want to talk about because it's
embarrassing and your friends would be
even more embarrassed to tell them about
it but in some cases it's you just don't
want to cause them pain or worry or sort
of hardship of their own and finding out
about them you know you made your mom
your financial situation may be badly
off and you know that if you mention it
to somebody else they will of course
step in and take care of it and you
don't want them to right so here are
some was printing out a dynamic that we
see going on today and he says so people
you know because of manly nature's we
should think of that it's sort of strong
a sort of nature's shrink from making
their friends share their pain and
unless a person is excessively
insensitive they can't hear the pain and
his pain his to them and they won't
suffer others to lament with them
because they're not given to lamentation
itself but rieger people I
says women ish med so people who are
more prone to you know being you know
effusive and their feelings we might say
like those who mourn with them and love
them as true friends and sympathizers so
he says well you know either way it kind
of fits the person but we want you to
try to be the higher person and the
Saudis adopting a more resolute add to
and if you think about this what happens
you know people on the bus sometimes
they're not feeling happy about
something so they turn to the other
person on the bus who they don't know
for me out and just start talking to
them about their misfortunes Arizona
would say well that's that's a sign
appeared on the kind of person that is
you know we make movies of course where
somebody carries around their grief
until finally something happens and then
I blurted it out and then we of course
as the audience of sympathizing with
them but the person who they're talking
to is like oh I didn't know you know my
lifetime movies are I think a lot of
those along those lines because it's
like a troll now Aristotle goes on he
says what else can we draw from this
says it may be thought that we want to
be eager to invite our friends to share
our good fortune but reluctant to ask
them to come to us in misfortune because
we should have part to others as little
as possible of what is evil right it
gives it a proverb here my own
misfortune is enough I don't mean to
impose any on you so he says we should
summon our friend story HD fleet when
they will be a great service to us at
the cost of little trouble to themselves
but conversely it's fitting we should go
uninvited and revelry to those in
misfortune for the it is the part of a
friend to render service especially to
those in need without being asked since
assistance so rendered is more noble and
more pleasant for both parties but to
the prosperous though we should go
readily to help them we should be slow
and going when it's a question of enjoy
they're good things aerosol saying you
know we should act differently towards
others than we do towards ourselves we
shouldn't be so quick to rely upon
friends to fill in the gaps but we
should be filling in our friends gaps as
quickly it was willingly and you know
with good cheer with goodwill as
possible so there's quite a bit to say
about how friendship works in misfortune
let's talk about about friendship in
prosperity and good times Arizona says
that prosperous are going to want
companions so it's not that they
actually need something that they don't
have from those companions like food or
drink or money or opportunities things
like that but rather they want to have
people that they can bet people that
they can provide something nice to you
know invite people to parties for
example right you know a dinner party
you're inviting guests into your home
and you're sharing food and probably
drink with them music you know you're
creating an occasion where people can
come together and you're not actually
saying unless you're not a very good
friend what am I going to get out of
this dinner party right that's sort of
risers and schemers do they hold their
parties like that but but good people
hold dinner parties because they want to
actually get a pleasure to their friends
they want to create an occasion where
some good things can happen conversation
does discussion and then we'll share
things with their friends that that's
part of what goes on when we're feeling
prosperity that's also one reason why
you know people who do have a lot of
resources sometimes you know end up
spending a lot of those resources in
precisely those kinds of activity this
is where the virtue of generosity and on
a larger scale the virtue of
magnificence come in friends also give
us pleasure in their return making our
life Pleasant it's not just about you
know being in a chamber by yourself you
know if the pleasure Center your brain
getting stimulated
friends are not just about dopamine you
know the way people like to talk about
these days you know sort of the magic
bullet that you know has to do with
everything it's about the the breath of
one's life sharing in friendship you
know having these connections is part of
what makes for a good life so even the
virtuous person has eres la the Senate
it is not going to be virtuous by
themselves they're going to want to have
friends with them another key idea here
is that human beings are by their very
nature social animals this is something
that Aristotle says politics he also
says it here in a coma can ethics social
animals is actually a translation of
cold etk which means animals that live
together in communities and we do that
we have the smallest community as the
family and then we go all the way up to
in rrna the nation state or perhaps even
the international community with all
sorts of other interpenetrating
communities along the way and we are
creatures that do indeed desire to have
connection with other human beings you
know grades animal that is you're
watching this on the internet right now
the internet is an expression of this
factor of us human beings being social
animals it also opens up a lot of
possibilities for people fleeing each
other and troll each other and you know
be mean to each other but that comes
about as a possibility on the basis of
this the last thing that I want to say
about prosperity or good times every son
is is very interesting expression which
he didn't coin but he repeats at several
times a friend is a second stuff another
you another person right who is whose
life you and to be in a relationship of
friendship means to a certain respect
get to know yourself through this other
person through how they see how they
interact with you now what's the off
shabbos this really has to do
primarily with friendships in terms of
virtue the good things about ourselves
and Aristotle says here we go if life is
desirable and especially so for good
people because existence is good for
them and so pleasant because they're
pleased by the perception of what is
intrinsically good and if the virtuous
person feels towards their friend in the
same way as that person feels towards
themselves for his friend is a second
self then just as the man's own
existence is desirable for that person
so or nearly so is the friends existence
also desirable but as we saw it is the
consciousness of oneself that is good
that makes existence desirable such
consciousness as pleasanton itself
therefore a man ought to share his
friends consciousness of his existence
this is attained by living together
conversing communicating their thoughts
to each other this is the meaning of
living together as applied to human
beings when we're doing that Aristotle
says we not only get to know the other
person we're also getting to know our
self sort of reflect it to ourselves in
the other person so if happiness
consists in virtuous activity we can't
actually see our own virtuous activity
as such entirely on our own I say
looking in a mirror the friend is indeed
the mirror through which we are able to
contemplate our own virtuous state and
see our own goodness and be happy about
it as a result now that's not the only
function the friend donna's and of
course this is reciprocal so if we're
too virtuous people my friend is also
getting to know him or herself through
me what does of course requires is that
we be virtuous we actually have
something to offer because this mirror
and factor can work as well if we have
band qualities our friend is
probably going to see those bad
qualities because they spend time with
us we communicate with them our motives
that are less than praiseworthy come to
the fore and then you know maybe they'll
conceal the fact that they know that
from us or maybe they will tell us about
that and we're actually gets fairly
happy so a lot depends here ah actually
having virtue but so you know in whether
it be in good times or bad times
Aristotle things we need friends and we
need them for different reasons